T
THIS IS THE TYPE OF
AREA IN WISCONSIN WHERE THE
FARMERS AND RANCHERS NEED TO
HAVE A CSERVATIVE APPROACH
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.>> AND THOSEY
ANNOYED PEOPLE TO STOP DRIVING
THE CAR YOU WILL ALL DRIVE ATESE
THINGS THAT YOU HEAR.
IT SOUNDS PUNITIVE AND MORE
EXPENSIVE
>> EXACTLY.
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES SHOULD
NOT OPPRESSED PEOPLE THAT
INSPIRE PEOPLE THE ENVIRONMENT
IS SOMETHING WE ALL HAVE A
PERSONAL CONNECTION AND WE ALL
LOVE THE PLANET AND THE GLOBE
WE LIVE ON WE EMBRACE THAT
LET'S MAKE THE MOST OF IT BY
BRINGING THE INSPIRATIONAL
APPROACH IS NOT ABOUT TELLING
PEOPLE WHAT TO DO BUT
EQUIPPING PEOPLE WITH THE BEST
RESOURCES TO BE EFFICIENT AND
STEWARDS OF OUR PLANET THAT IS
TOTALLY DIFFERENT DEPENDING ON
WHERE YOU LIVE OR HOW YOU LIVE
IN WHAT COUNTRY YOU LIVE
IN.
AGAIN WE HAVE BEEN ON A FALSE
DICHOTOMY OF THE GREEN NEW
DEAL AND THAT IS BAD FOR OUR
ENVIRONMENT AND OUR ECONOMY.
YOU HEARD IT HERE FIRST THIS
IS THE YEAR CONSERVATIVES CAN
AND WILL RETAKE THAT
ENVIRONMENTAL DIALOGUE WE HAD
BEFORE AND WE WILL AGAIN.
STEVE: I LOVE THE WAYOU PUT
THAT.
YOU ARE COMPLETELY RIGHT IT IS
INSPIRING TO SEE HOW YOU HAVE
BUILT ALLIES AROUND THE SEND
CONSERVATIVE LEADERS LIKE RON
DESANT